hey guys welcome back to another video
and today's video is going to be about
one really quick thing that happened on
reddit today just a really quick thing
about for honor and then the rest of its
going to be dedicated to in kind of like
upcoming stuff for this channel or not
nothing huge just more content than I
wanted to push out but we could talk
about that that will be later in the
video anyway the first thing I wanted to
discuss about was about for honor and
from August 10th to August 13th it's
going to have a free player weekend so
if you have any friends who were
skeptical before honor or have never
played that tell them tell them to
download it and hopefully we can attract
some new players it will be on all
consoles Xbox ps4 and PC and if you play
during the weekend and think that Foran
is that good all of your progress will
be saved and carry over so you won't
lose anything so this is great I'm
actually really glad they're doing this
especially with the start of season 3
coming up very soon and won't be a good
time for some of the new players to pick
up the game or some of the old players
that dropped it in the game of the past
seasons to come back also if they're
doing these free weekends now hopefully
that means there's going to be more free
weekends and on top of that they're
going to start adding more different
versions like double steal weekend or
double xp or something like that in the
future it might not be needed though but
it would be a great it'd be great
addition to have with the constant
amount of weekly content we'd be getting
it'd be really good to have a double
steal weekend occasionally and then
lastly this is something I wanted to
start doing I want to hear what you guys
think about it but anyway I want to
start uploading a lot more as you know I
normally do a lot of news in discussion
type videos but with the season with the
beginning of season 3 coming up I was
thinking that I could do some gameplay
of the of the heroes the new heroes to
be specific as well as guides to the new
characters as well I'm not exactly the
greatest afore honor but it'd be a nice
filler to use when there isn't much news
to be covered of course I'm always going
to be covering the patch notes and
upcoming changes like normal I just
started add a little bit more content to
this channel and also wanted to start
streaming as well the only problem with
this is that I've never actually
livestream before so the first couple
might be a bit rough and unorganized and
I also don't want to have a situation
where I live stream and not too many
people feel interested or won't watch it
and might not seem that bad but it's
always been a personal fear of mine this
is just why I've been holding off
streaming for this for this long but if
you're interested in seeing the stream
on occasion and tell me in the comments
and anything I talked about whether it
be the free weekend or some additional
changes coming at the beginning of
season 3 or the content I make tell me
in the comments below you guys think I'd
really love to know it'd be really
greatly appreciated well like like
always if you did enjoy the video this
rather short video hit it with the like
button if you just like to hit the
dislike button and then if you're new
subscribe for loads of four on our
content coming in the future and then
while you're at it hit that Bell right
next to it and it takes a couple seconds
and you can be part of the notification
squad and never miss one of my uploads
with that guys I hope you have a great
rest of your day and good bye